[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode of
Kos and I give you none other than
generation 1 prime studios Megatron as I
was doing this video I I came across so
many different aspects of it right
because in the childhood you see
cartoons and you like you know um you
look at them it's a it's a base layer so
you always thought Megatron is bad you
know Optimus Prime and the Autobots it's
good that they're fighting for for
Humanity you know Megatron they tink you
know and the Decepticons they take
notice the purple right yeah today I'm a
Decepticon yo so check it out right um I
gave you Thundercats they gave me he-man
I gave you lying I'll give you my bro I
gave you a key men give you Skeletor
now I'm give you Megatron and then you
know who's coming next now always
remember I start off with their
antagonists and then I give you the
protagonist afterwards that's the
villain and then the hero alright
because you always got to start with
chaos to bring some calm and normalcy
into the situation so I used to read the
books back in the days and first it
started off with you know um me looking
at the cartoons so as a kid you just see
black and white you don't really see it
for what it is right so
not knowing that when I read the books I
found out that they were really like the
Republicans and the Democrats right see
you like what how was that there was a
civil war going on on Cybertron right
Cybertron is the home planet of the of
the Autobots of Decepticons of the
Transformers right so they had a civil
war it was civil unrest now before it
was civil unrest they will work in the
unisons autobots and decepticons is
working together and then they became an
uprising it was problems it was a
shortage on food which is in it Energon
and money and and stuff like that and it
became such a civil unrest that they
fought and the warring factions was at
odds with each other well there were
more Decepticons than the Autobots at
that time there was outnumbering them
that the Autobots had to flee so they
fled Cybertron and in fleeing Cybertron
they found earth so you gonna say like
it's so crazy when you get a chance to
read the books and you see the expanded
universe other than the candy-coated
stuff that they give you in the cartoons
you know for kids you know when you
started to read it and understand it by
the way could not stand none of Michael
Bay stuff but he had the the basic law
of the Transformers down he didn't have
the look but he had the law down and
what I appreciate was that was he
explained to you the whole legacy and
story of the Transformers so you can get
a better feel you see once you read the
graphic novels and you know you got all
that stuff down Michael Bay did do a
great job and conveying that to the
public so you know I have to commend
them on that
and he wanted to put his twist on it you
know every director wants to do that
wasn't my take on him I could not stand
not one look on any of those
transformers and always revert to Gen 1
any true transformer fan we're gonna say
that right with bias so we're gonna say
that Gen 1 is what it is now let's get
into the statute oh wait a second I
didn't talk about the motivations of
Megatron Megatron is a complex villain
he's not a villain that you would say is
in any form of the way is how can you
say like you can you can pick down his
motivations it may seem that way from
the TV show but from the books he is
knocked that way he he fights for his
people he was elected by his people and
see how the Decepticons rule they ruled
by only the strong survive so the
strongest of the the Decepticons will be
the leader all right
um and that way they can ensure that
they ranks going down the line is as
powerful you know Soundwave the
second-in-command you know stuff like
that Starscream always wanted to be a
leader but he was a coward you know he
would turn tail in battle with Megatron
that Soundwave when these guys will
fight to the bitter end
so the motivations of Megatron has
always been self-preservation and the
preservation of his species his kind of
Decepticons and to make sure that he can
bring Cybertron back to its dominance
into his prominent form as they felt
that they were a better species in the
galaxy
alright so Megatron's motivations aren't
as transparent as they seemed at first
until you dig deeper into the character
and why the clash between Autobots and
Decepticons was so impactful in my youth
and as you know an adult you get to
understand political parties and things
of that nature and everything isn't
always black and white you have to dig
through layers to see what resonates
with yourself alright um and you can
tell that the Transformers
is a metaphor for society as a whole but
let's get to this probably one statute
problem studios is probably one of my
best this is my tía how I do it I do XM
studios prime one and they can flip-flop
because prior one puts out some serious
work and then you know sideshow sideshow
is um is in there they have a large
range of you know financially accessible
statutes where Prime one is you starting
off at eighteen hundred nine hundred and
you're going up to the 2003 you know so
you got to be balling around in that
area to get to these statues um Megatron
the level of detail on the base want to
start off with the base we're gonna
start off with the Decepticon logo
beautiful purple beautiful purple you
see it the base is when he first came to
the planet when Megatron and Optimus
Prime was fighting they fought on this
mountain it was a it was a cliff
overlooking a waterfall they battle they
battled there that's where the staging
grounds for the fight was and they
displayed different options this is not
the XM the e.x edition this is the
regular edition so I don't have his um
he has a ball and chain and it's made
out of Energon so but he glows his uh
his cannon on his arm glows purple his
eyes glow red it doesn't have too many
it doesn't have switch out pieces but
the level of detail on this character is
incredible you can see from the shiny
metal features that it looks like metal
which it isn't but it looks just like
metal you can see the paint job is
impeccable
this is a statue that you guys have been
asking me to do and I've buckled in and
I got you to statue I've done it for you
and I truly appreciate the level of
detail Prime one
to get this statute to us um i'ma leave
you on this note I want you to hit that
joint button down at the bottom this is
the part of the video where you hit that
joy button and you like follow and
subscribe also go to Lords of gaming
dotnet where you can get the dimensions
for this statue and you get a brief
synopsis and written form and you can
also look and read a lot of opinion
pieces that we have here from a lot of
our brilliant writers and also look at
Lord attics are hard gaming reviews we
also bring in new stuff to you so you
can go to the website to get that stuff
you also go there to look at the last
word with loyal kognito and new bonta's
that stuff is incredible another
fabulous show from my Lords and you can
go to get old episodes of kls also
combat talk with the king that's with me
that's with boxing
some MMA and you get that in there
listen finish watching the video we are
you gonna see more of this statue
without me talking and you get a chance
to see video pitches and I'll see you
next week when I'm gonna bring you the
protagonist Optimus Prime hey never
forget
stay collector
[Music]
yes DJ
[Music]
[Music]
djay
[Music]
[Music]
djay
[Music]
[Music]
djay
[Music]